I picture you and Jodie Foster you and
Kristy McNichol a big nickel it's so
funny how back in the 70s we didn't know
like did you do you know that Jodie
Foster was gay or Kristy McNichol was or
is that not even talk Michael no he had
no idea no clue Michael Jackson yeah do
you think he was yeah yeah yeah I think
so too but you know you never know why
do you say yeah they convincingly did
you know him yeah yeah there's a story
in there too about him and I doing a
television show we did in Swiss Germany
and German Swiss area they saw him and
he asked me what was like tim has to be
what did you tell him I told him you can
find out for yourself
you know I was gonna show him do you
think it was he do you think he was into
you is that way they don't know I would
imagine yeah my videos kind of trying to
set something up yeah yeah and you're
like let's nip this in the bud right now
looking back do you kind of wish you had
done it just for a great story Michael
Jackson but somebody like Jim okay
Michael Jackson comes to you I jerk off
with him you heard absolutely he's
Michael Jackson mr. King upon getting
him back then it was a good egg right
what era of Michael Jackson was this
back in 78 this is the off the wall this
is no this is this is when he's with the
Jackson 5 Holly wants to like this in
later years of the Jackson 5 okay but
you got that energy from him that he was
more than just asking oh yeah so were
you surprised you said something to in
one of your interviews
about I want to say it was something
about you said every chickenhawk wants a
part of you because you a young guy you
were like 14 15
what are you Chicken Hawk are you
talking about the kid touches and yeah
what was that experience like because
now everybody's talking about it and
it's kind of yeah they you know they all
wanted to
don't want to get to know me better
don't want to hang out take quaaludes
who producers or guys over your age or
older guys older guys yes people that
want to avoid yeah and you knew I mean
were you able to figure out already
quickly who to avoid here and what what
people's motives weren't my bottom is
still version good for you yes for you
congratulations on that did they trip
but did they try oh yeah so how what do
you credit you being smart enough to
avoid those situations too right because
I think a lot of teeth would stinks a
lot of people at that age are so eager
to be successful yeah that when those
situations come up they feel like oh I
have to do this or I want to fit in or I
want to be cool that just wasn't this
wasn't something that I was willing to
do right this wasn't there you know did
they get the vibe that you weren't gonna
do it or do they think were you gonna
kind of just like keeping them thinking
maybe no but you gotta be like that even
to you but you gotta be I know what you
mean yeah no no nothing like that I
don't know I think that they they just
just like the way I looked
did your mom know that this stuff was
like not really out there and they know
my mom was very trusting right she's
trusting yeah not to have a greatest
thing to do when your kids aren't show
business know so she would leave you
along with these people assuming that
everything was gonna be okay yeah would
you tell her you know yeah I told her
sometimes you know like stuff she was
very uh taken back way was she super
invested in the idea of her kids being
like that she want you guys in show
business so she didn't kind of want to
believe the negative stuff yeah yeah
yeah because if you go and say this is
what's going on the only thing she can
do is pull you out but then the show
business stuff is over right yeah it's
it's hard if your parent your kid is
really good at something like you [ __ ]
Wow I don't say creep sorry meaning I
know it's it's it's like a shitty thing
to have to deal with I don't have kids
but I mean I think show businesses girls
like it's that hard yeah for a parent to
be able to be like okay let's prioritize
here no no I don't mean that I mean it's
hard to kind of face that this is what
it is yeah like it's kind of hard that
you're like wow I'm asked to take them
from all this young stuff one more Jim
and Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM Avenue